foreign
interconnect offers a ton of the Vantage
by enabling you to reliably transfer
data between your own premises and
Google Cloud networks through a directly
low latency connection
on the other hand maintaining
troubleshooting connectivity shoes in
hybrid networks adds a lot of complexity
today I'm here to walk you through how
to troubleshooting resolve the
connectivity issues between on-premises
and Google Cloud virtual private cloud
or vpcs connected through Cloud
interconnect
let's start with a sneak peek on what
cloud interconnect has to offer Cloud
interconnect offers two options dedicate
interconnect and partner interconnect
well here you can see a dedicated
interconnect which provides a directive
physical connection between your
on-premises network and Google's Network
next
we have partner interconnect where the
connectivity is through a supported
sales provider
I will use this dedicated interconnect
topology for the demo it consists of two
routers Google Edge router and
on-premises router they are in the same
collocation facility
then we have a cloud order connect with
a border gated protocol or bgp to the
on-premises router
let's now dive into the demo go to the
Google Cloud console and type the word
interconnect in the search bar
check the status of the interconnect
this BJP session is down I wonder why
the bgp session can be done due to
multiple reasons include
misconfigurations so let's verify each
configuration from the borrow app that
is from layer 1 to the application layer
here is the checklist of what needs to
be verified
one is the interface status app
2. did I configure develop ID correctly
three is the on-premes router IP address
in the same subnet as the cloud router
enabled
5 is the as number configured correctly
six is the M2 value the same on both
ends
foreign
I checked the interface status of the
on-premes router and it is up
OK let's verify the villain ID is
configured correctly the line ID is 1100
on the Google Cloud site and it is 1100
on the on-prem router as well
the bgp peers IP addresses are
configured correctly both are in the
same subnet and the on-prem router IP is
the second host of the subnet
the mq values are the same on both ends
next
check the Colorado as number it is 65
000. this is correct
let's check the as number for the bgp
peer which is the on-prem router
oops
the as number is configured with a 64
501 and should be 64 500. haha that's
the problem
let's correct it go to the interconnect
select interconnect ID a d2bjp session
correct as number click save
hey now the BJP session is established
sometimes the issue could be in layer 1
or layer 2 connectivity for these
scenarios you might need to contact your
sales provider that provisioning the
circuit for you
for more information about Cloud
interconnect and troubleshooting issues
check out the following documents thanks
for watching
foreign
[Music]